I've just been watching the sexy ladies in the PMC commercials.
No...
No, hearing this...
Hearing this intro music...
Hearing Old Snake theme...
It kind of kills me.
I'm already dead, but...
It kills me.
No!
Welcome to Metal Gear Solid 4.
Ah...
The red dot is a nice touch.
I know it's the wrong eye, but it's fine.
It's fine.
Old Snake...
Nate, happy birthday!
Singing a quick happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Nate.
Happy birthday!
It is... It is time.
It's Orca Day?
Can Orca get a happy Orca Day?
Is it actually your birthday?
I finally finished MGS4 in preparation for this stream.
Oh my gosh.
It is actually.
Just invert the model?
I thought about that.
I did think about flipping me on the screen.
But it might flip me off.
VTuber has changed.
I'm VTuber who has changed.
Oh, Snake.
Snake, no!
Oh my gosh.
Full disclosure, I have played this game before.
You know, I've played all of Metal Gear series.
Metal Gear Solid series.
But...
Wait, which one are we gonna get now?
I don't know.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Orca.
Oh this one is weird.
This one they are just like dancing in the sky.
Okay.
It's like the most dystopian one I'd say.
From behind she looks like Darth Vader.
Oh, Nier Automata.
Why are they so big?
Oh my god.
What is happening?
I can see some death stranding in this.
I get what you mean.
No peace without war.
The PMC commercials are kind of wack.
Not kind of, they are very wack.
I can't believe Snake has become a hag.
And we'll do summer podcast with Otacon.
My kokoro is not so prepared for this one I think.
I already feel myself so...
But, yeah.
I'm excited to play through it again.
Don't worry Mito, MGS4 gets better with age.
Even those parts.
I love MGS4.
I understand why some people are kind of lukewarm on it.
I think it does have some parts that are just like...
But I love this game.
Those crunchy PS3 graphics.
Yes, I am on my PS3.
I am, I am.
In fact, when I was going to play this, I was like, where is the game?
It's not in the case.
It's actually been in...
It's been in my PS3 since I last played it.
I haven't needed my PS3 since.
It's been in there for like the past two years.
I was somehow gifted a membership despite watching a VOD.
It's spooky, isn't it?
Spooky.
It didn't look like any of the BNB companies.
No, I'm pretty sure it was.
It looked like the mask was like a wolf or something.
So, yeah, my PS3 has just been holding on to the disc.
Until now.
This game is a good starting point to the MGS series.
Shut up!
Don't even joke!
You kept the disc waiting.
Truly.
But I assume that maybe we should be okay for the loading screens.
Probably.
Thank you for the superchat!
This is a PS3 game?
It looks so good for a PS3 game.
Props to Kojima.
Yeah, this is PS3.
Thank you for the superchat.
Can't wait to see your no kill and no alerts run.
Although, I do want to try and get the...
The solar gun.
Tiny people!
I hate.
Why does this look like an ad for a graphics card?
This is my favorite MGS.
I actually checked to see if it was on my shelf of a game store yesterday.
Oh, on the shelf of a game store yesterday.
It wasn't.
Now you're playing it the next day?
Have you been haunting me?
To be fair, this has been on my schedule all week.
Watching Snake smoking for 15 minutes is part of the experience.
I know, I love that part too.
Oh my gosh, you guys!
Speaking of...
I got a package in the mail today of some very important...
Oh no way, I don't think I'll be able to show you.
Okay, I'll just post it to Twitter later.
But I got a package in the mail of some very important Metal Gear things from my collection.
Why not?
Because my second monitor is completely taken over by...
And if I exit out, it'll be all messed up.
So...
Tumblr...
Did I get those yet?
Hello, Mint!
I tried to write something in the chat and I can't see my messages.
Am I blocked?
I don't even remember posting anything in the chat.
I... don't block people.
So...
It's probably YouTube.
I think, yeah, you might be Shadow Band.
My dad played 3 and my first one was MGS4.
No!
Why was your first one before?
Oh my god.
Oh my god, Solidus, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Nanomachines.
Yeah, it's the Patriots that are blocking you.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, oh gosh.
I see the Metal Gear stream.
I can finally let my brain rot be free.
I kind of get like overloaded on brain rot.
Like, I need a place to dump my thoughts and my feelings, you know?
And I don't.
Am I getting the updated version of Snake's Figma?
Of course I am.
So, okay.
Alright.
Are we ready to get started?
If someone tells you that they became a VTuber because you inspired them to become one, would that make you feel proud?
I mean, I would be honored about that, yeah.
Okay, one last, one last, one last, one last commercial.
Sorry, my first Metal Gear was 5.
This is what I'm gonna do to you!
This is what I'll do to you if your first Metal Gear is 5!
No!
Never a shot in the dark.
Damn.
That one didn't even show up.
You need to rehire.
If it isn't Saucy Minto, please watch out that you won't...
That you don't become saucier, otherwise you will start dripping mint sauce from you.
Eww, eww.
Okay.
Could be worse, it could have been survive.
I got, I got... Okay, so in the mail I got a couple of Metal Gear things today.
One of them I accidentally forgot... Oh yeah, someone mentioned the tumblers.
I have not received those yet.
The ones that I won from...
From Toreba, I haven't gotten those yet.
I wonder how long shipping usually takes.
Ah, it's been forever!
If I load game from my old game...
Do I get the like... There's no new game plus stuff, is there?
So sad.
I don't think I played... I didn't do like any special ranking.
And I'm not trying for any special ranking this time either.
Because I just like to enjoy the game, honestly.
I just like to take my time.
There is new game plus?
There is?
Okay.
Can I earn trophies?
You must start playing from new game.
Oh well.
Okay.
I forgot what I was saying.
I've been saying multiple things and then remembering other things.
My brain is a little slow today.
Sorry, I'm kind of sleepy.
The boss extreme.
No!
Sunlight.
Yeah, I want to get the solar gun.
I think you have to...
I know for sure I played non-lethal with the bosses.
Like the boss babes.
The beauty boss babe.
I can't remember the beauty and the beasts.
I can't remember what they're called.
I just keep calling them boss babes.
The beauty and the beast.
But then I think you also have to be non-lethal with the PMCs.
And then also in the first...
The first two acts?
Or is it the second act?
I can't remember.
I looked it up.
And then you get all their little trophies.
And then you...
Get...
You get their statues and then you can get the solar gun.
It's kind of confusing.
I'm sorry, Arthur.
I really don't know.
I'm sorry.
If you were...
If you were blocked...
I can't really check right now.
But...
I really... It probably was an accident.
If it happened, but I...
Usually if someone gets timed out, they're timed out.
But I don't usually block from chat unless it's like a spammer.
But lots of people get shadow banned very often on YouTube, so...
Yeah, people in chat have experienced it too, so...
Yeah, yeah.
Is PS3 the only way to play MGS4 nowadays?
Officially, yes.
There is like a...
What is it?
Like a 60fps version on PC that you can technically play, but...
But as of like an official way, yeah, it's kind of... Yeah, you can emulate it.
Yeah, but it's not as good.
Actually, didn't they fix it?
Or is it still not so good?
I don't remember.
I heard it's buggy.
I can't remember if they recently fixed it though.
I feel like I remember hearing it...
It was really, really bad and then I remember hearing that it maybe is a little more stable now.
But I have my PS3 so I can...
So I can play it.
Sorry, that scared the hell out of me.
Oh my God!
David Hader!
Accomplished actor, screenwriter, voice of a generation.
A citizen of the world.
Ripped from a comfortable childhood in Canada.
Thrown into the turbulent waters of Adelaide.
Also, the other voice actress.
A bit of a spoiler for later in the game.
Well, my dad got transferred overseas and...
He's Canadian?
He is!
I love hearing David Hader's Japanese.
Biggest secret...
Oh my God, we're going to hear it right here.
But he...
We'll never know!
After the baby I ballooned?
I thought she said after I was a baby.
My own baby.
Baby.
Husband, baby.
Baby, baby, baby.
Husband, baby, baby.
Oh, those look like boobs.
Baby, baby, baby.
Shideo1.
Bogie here, welcome back to 2014.
Oh, it's 2014!
Shideo2.
Oh.
Oh my God, we love Susan.
Can we get the boom mic closer to her please?
Oh, I hate this one.
I forgot.
Thanks for the...
Oh, thanks for the raid!
Hello, hello.
We're just now starting MGS4.
Oh, we watched this one earlier.
Wait, is this the sexy one?
Yeah, baby!
Superficier.
Say thank you to the sanguifers.
Snake was James Bond.
Would you want to be James Bone?
James Bone?
Oh yeah.
Oh, we watched this one too?
We saw this one too?
Oh, the praying man.
Goodbye.
Aw man.
Thank you for all the gifts.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
James Bond.
The not too distant future on a tired battlefield.
War has become routine.
Aw man.
I hate this font.
I still hate this font.
Oh, it's so terrible.
Aw, so many familiar names.
Such a good intro.
Aw man.
He'll say it.
He's old.
Give him a minute.
Catch his breath.
Give him a minute to catch his breath.
Shhh.
He said the thing.
Sorry, it's like a meme.
Genetic control.
Information control.
Don't say poop control.
No.
Oh gosh, this opening sequence is so stressful.
I hate the geckos.
War has changed.
When the battlefield is under total control, war becomes routine.
Ooh, it's incoming.
I hate those trauma sounds.
Who let this old man on the field?
Who let this guy fight?
He should be retired.
Oh my god.
Game kinda loud.
Yeah, I'm adjusting it as it goes.
It's hard because sometimes the voice is so low and the fighting sounds so loud.
But also I want you to be able to hear it.
Oh god.
Why did you break?
Kill that guy right there.
He's literally just pointing at me.
Oh yeah, shoot him.
I love auto-aim.
Let's see, we got a stun knife.
Now we got a ration.
Meal ready to eat, baby.
I forgot about the psyche.
I forgot about our stress level.
It's too dangerous to stay in one spot.
Get wrecked, then get out of there as soon as possible.
Ooh, Otacon!
I'm trying to remember how to control again.
Yeah.
Thanks Otacon.
Crouch walk is...Oh crouch walk!
Yes!
Yeah, crouch walk baby!
I am.
I gotta wiggle my way over there, OK?
Otacon's backseating!
Oh god, here it comes.
Oh no.
HyÅjishinkawa!
Yeah!
Do the super slow crawl.
You guys are sickos!
Gotta keep the cigarette in the mouth.
You know what?
According to Peace Walker, we have vaping.
But Snake doesn't choose to use it and I really appreciate that honestly.
Just keep moving.
OK, hold on.
Here you guys go!
Exactly what you wanted!
Are you happy?
Oh, I just stepped over that guy.
You got anything for me to take?
Oh, actually yeah.
This is the gameplay I subscribe for.
Exactly.
I give the people what they want.
Vote for me though.
Vote for slow...for ground humping Snake.
It ain't gonna be me.
I'm not the backup here.
Why do you guys have such shitty aim?
Just be better.
What was that sound?
Welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Two steps and then a cutscene.
I know I love this game!
You got my vote.
I hear it.
Do you guys hear it?
Oh no!
It might be loud.
Incoming loud.
Would there be so many...
crickets and cicada noises if you're in like the desert?
I hate these guys.
They're fun in...they're fun in Revengeance because I can slice and dice them.
I love the crunchy FPS.
Do I have a gun?
I don't have anything.
I'm just gonna leave.
I'm gonna get out of here.
I can't see the door.
Oh shoot.
Don't worry about me.
I literally have trapped myself.
You don't see me.
Actually I can't tell if he sees me.
Oh good.
He's killing other people.
We can go.
North!
Which way is north?
I'm going the wrong way.
Ok, we're fine.
Hello.
Oh, you're not my enemy.
Nevermind.
North is...I have a literal compass and I'm still lost.
Don't mind me.
Ok, you know what?
I can't read...I can't read compasses clearly.
Everyone?
This guy over here is just screaming.
Oh no!
I think it's this way.
I can't...yeah, it's over here.
I was like, I know I'm going the right way.
I was like, I know it's over here, but I went to the wall instead.
That's why I got lost.
That's no good.
Oh, that's no good.
Old Snake is like, I have fought helicopters.
You are no match for me.
His feet are kicking in the air.
He's so pathetic.
Oh my god, he's gonna do it.
Old man...
Look up.
Oh my god, I have a figure of that pose.
These things are too good.
You're gonna choke on that thing, Snake.
Big boy.
I love that they're modeled after Rex.
They're so cute.
Oh my god, ye old faithful.
Ye old faithful, get in there.
My god, the feet are insane.
So awesome.
I love the camo in this game, baby.
No place to hide.
Oh my god, it's scanning my DNA.
Pick it up, Snake.
Ok, now we know this is extremely inaccurate.
We know this is extremely inaccurate because...
Because the AI was fooled by the box.
Not the watermelon, it's still good to eat.
No place for Hideo.
He just smashed, he just cooked it for us.
Or cut it for us.
He cooked us a good watermelon.
What's wrong with my brain?
Again.
Old Snake again.
This game is so depressing.
Metal Gear Solid 5!
Clappies.
Everybody clap.
I see something and I clap.
No.
Save that for later.
People wonder why Kojima made so many stealth games.
His name is literally Hide-o.
Hideo.
Cinema!
Ok.
Ok, baby.
God, this suit is so sexy.
Konami.
Nusef.
The cheeks.
I know!
My goodness gracious.
He may be old, but them cheeks still clapping.
True.
I don't know why...
Well, I don't want to say any spoilers.
I'm not going to say any spoilers.
Sorry, I almost got ahead of myself about someone crying.
No spoilers!
Sorry.
I didn't want to say that though, just because, you know, there are probably some people watching that don't know MGS4.
So let's...
Oh!
Let's keep the spoilers to a minimum.
Baby!
No!
I know, what the hell.
Build the 1-100 model.
Rex, good luck!
Chat is going to dunk on you so hard if you miss any of those splash back things.
I'm used to chat dunking on me.
Your early aging symptoms look like classic Fairness Syndrome, but none of the tests were able to pinpoint the cause.
Judging by how rapidly the aging has progressed, I'd say...
Cringe disease.
No!
Snake, let's try another doctor.
Yeah.
Oh, I missed it.
Sorry, my vision was blurred with tears, OK?
Well, you would have just seen flashbacks of MGS1.
Oh, here we go.
Oh god.
The one time I do click it, I have to see her stupid ass face.
Go away, Naomi!
They are like, do you remember Naomi?
Colonel.
That's just a suit.
Do you remember Naomi?
I try not to.
Yeah, that is kind of foreshadowing, huh?
Use your words, Snake.
Use your words.
It's rapid aging, but rapid...
Rapid cavemanning too.
Oh, remember that guy?
Remember that guy?
Why did they only show Liquid from MGS1?
Brother.
He's got to go fight his brother.
He's gonna go fight his brother.
I know people make fun of the cutscenes in this game, how it's literally a quote-unquote interactive movie.
But I honestly prefer it to be just a cutscene.
OK.
Hear me out.
Hear me out, OK?
Hear me out a little bit.
I find that it's more offensive when a game pretends like it's gameplay for me to walk around and then view something as if it's a cutscene.
Rather than just having a cutscene.
Like, if they're just like, oh, you...
Like, I feel like they're making fun of me.
If they're like, oh, but it's gameplay if you get to do this and that while it's actually like a cutscene.
Like, say we were doing that cutscene and like Snake walked around and could like sit and crouch or whatever at the grave.
You know, things like that.
F to pay respects.
That's what I'm saying.
Like you have to do like a press X to shake Otacon's hand or something like that.
I feel like that is more offensive to me than just...
Because it's such a lazy way of gameplay.
Just have the damn cutscene.
Like, yeah, follow Otacon.
Yeah!
So, I know people are just like, this is my favorite interactive movie.
But, at least I don't feel like I'm being treated like a baby.
Okay, let's continue.
My very serious take.
Sorry, I'm so excited.
9, 2, 5, 9, 0, 3, 6, 0.
0, 5, 4, 8, 8, 2, 4, 6, 6, 5, 2.
Also, Speedy Fire, I will sing you happy birthday.
After, whenever the next cutscene ends.
Act 1!
Liquid Sun.
Humming.
Okidoki.
Praying Mantis.
Hello?
Lizards.
Yeah,
I know.
They're crazy.
Hmm.
Fans.
Yeah.
Mark 2.
Okay.
Sunny!
Got it.
Okay.
Look at his little smile.
I also hate how the codec looks in this game.
Okidoki.
Okay, I have a birthday song to sing to you.
Can I get a happy birthday from your boss?
Of course!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Speedy Fire.
Happy birthday!
Are we going to watch the mission briefing?
Is there one in this?
I actually don't remember.
Where is Gas Snake or Plasma Snake?
In your heart.
And GS4 is a love letter to the fans.
It's a classic.
Yeah, I know.
I love it.
Main menu briefing.
Oh, I did skip it then.
My bad.
It's okay though.
I feel like...
Don't they go over the briefing though?
I don't remember.
I thought that it was also a cutscene in the game.
It's my first time seeing this game.
All my experience with MGS has been through your streams.
I'll be honest, this wasn't what I expected from the E3 trailer we watched.
Yes, it's quite different, right?
And now we have Octocamo, baby!
Can you make Old Man Snake do the worm?
I already did it.
I'm not going to make him do it all the time.
Okay, hold on.
L1, fire with R1.
Okay.
R1, fire.
Open the window.
Switch between semi and full auto.
Okay.
Okey dokey.
We're going to go...
This way?
Wait.
Oh gosh.
Okay, reading the map.
Ew, stinky.
Oh, I got some ammo.
Okay, we got to go around though, I think.
Is this going to keep auto-aim on?
I didn't turn it on.
It was on automatically.
I don't even remember how to turn it off, so...
Oh, hey guys.
Just don't... Just ignore me.
Just ignore me.
Oh, okay.
They will ignore me.
Oh, I hope the tank also ignores me.
Do you think it's select?
I don't know.
They are ignoring me.
Oh, hello guys.
Holy moly.
Oh, okay.
Here we go.
Got it!
Who the hell saw me?
Are you kidding me right now?
I'm running.
Bye!
I'm going!
Yeah, I'm going!
I forgot how dramatic the...
The death scene is so funny.
Oh my gosh.
Who saw me?
I think it was these guys.
Where are they?
Actually, where did they go?
Who's over here?
Oh, I can't go this way.
Okay.
Let's see.
Avoid that area.
Otacon, this is literally where you put the Mark 2.
So honestly, it's your fault that I have to go over there.
You're the one trying to kill me, buddy.
Okay.
Octocam, baby.
Worm crawl.
I'm crawling, okay?
It's honestly Otacon's fault.
So, we can blame him for all of our mistakes.
We're at 80% camo.
85%, let's go.
And now, not a lot.
80%.
85%.
Oh, what's in here?
Oh, are you my friend?
Friend or foe?
I can't remember.
Are you friend?
Anyway.
Oh my God!
Oh
my God!
He's dead!
Nevermind.
Shoot him again.
Oh, just kidding.
He's dead.
Ice cream!
It freaked me out.
Wait, hold on.
I have to remember how to punch and stuff.
Oh, that's auto-aim.
Okay.
Punch.
Punch?
How do I punch?
I can't punch?
Okay, weird.
Is it R1?
Oh.
Sorry, it's been a long while since I've...
Okay, cool.
It's been a minute since I... And let's equip instead our stun knife.
Let's see.
Ready the knife with L1.
Use with R1 to strike!
And R2 to shock attack.
Cool.
Alright, punch.
Punch, baby!
Alright.
That guy...
Went in there, so I'm gonna go...
I'm gonna go this way.
Holy moly, he's like right there.
Yeah, you can leave.
Where the hell is the Mark II?
Why'd you put it so far away, Otacon?
Oh my god.
No way.
Nothing?
No one?
Please don't see me.
We're camoing?
Camo?
Is it this way?
I thought I saw somebody.
We're going?
We're sneaking?
We're being real sneaky?
Worm.
Okay, you guys wanna see the worm?
Here you go.
You call this nothing?
What's wrong with you?
I remember this.
Old Snake has camo-toe.
Don't call it that, please!
Wait, is he... He's got a wedgie for sure.
We can say that at the least.
Wait.
No, no.
Get up.
Get up, Snake.
How do I get up here?
I can't remember.
No, Snake.
Come on!
Hold forward and triangle.
Oh, there it is.
It was only letting me...
Why would you grab there?
Snake!
Why?
What?
That's what I'll do to you if you play MGS5 first.
We're so sneaky.
Super sneaky.
I don't know if anybody's in here.
Actually, is there anything in here for us to grab?
A moose?
What?
Oh, what's this?
We got a regain?
You don't need that.
You have a fresh set of hair, Snake.
You don't need that at all.
What's over here?
I'm just exploring a bit now.
I played MGS5 first.
Is that a Russian?
Yup.
This is definitely one of the games that I... Well, I can honestly say I only played it once because...
It's quite a long...
Oh, hell no.
No!
What was I gonna say?
It's a longer game, but I've watched the cutscenes because the cutscenes are so good.
OK, let's just wait.
Our stress is going up.
He's not gonna look in here, right?
You'll see all the other lockers open and only this one shut.
Yeah, don't look in the only closed locker, buddy.
I think we're fine.
Damn, I didn't see that guy at all.
OK, don't go up there.
I hear him stepping.
Oh my god, don't do it.
Don't you dare.
I hate you so...
I stabbed him!
I'm old, please!
Oh my god, I'm just...
Stab!
Why can't I stab them?
Oh my god, not the reinforcement.
OK, I think it's time for a gun.
Oh.
Don't go up the stairs.
What a bastard.
That guy is seeing me and then opening the locker.
I hate this AI.
It's my karma for ripping off that guy's peepee, isn't it?
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
Advanced AI.
Too advanced for me.
Wait, is it not here anymore?
Oh, OK.
OK, quiet steps, Snake.
Quiet steps.
Okey dokey.
I tried... OK.
Ready the knife with L1 and then I kept pressing R2?
Maybe I have to... I don't know.
Does it have to be stuck in their body for the electric shock attack?
Or I think they just kept hitting me and I... you know.
This guy, does he turn around?
Don't you do it.
Don't you turn...
Very...
Very inconspicuous, Snake.
We love that.
Dumbass.
Oh gosh.
I wonder if I can go up and CQC him.
How do I do the codec in this?
Here we go.
Otacon, can I attack this guy?
Yeah, and you put it so far away.
Attempt it?
OK, we can attempt it.
You know what?
Let's attempt it, because what?
He's all by him lonesome?
It looks like it's like... he's there.
If I dot...
Oh my God.
Nobody.
We need to turn around now!
You stood there for like ten fucking minutes!
As soon as I start going...
You think he'll... Oh, I'm gonna run.
Nope, nobody here.
Exactly.
Isn't that great?
Where am I?
Can you... There we go.
Alright, nice.
I hear steps.
Get down, snake.
Snake, get down, down.
Like, get down on the ground, ground.
OK, are they gonna see me?
I'm at 85%.
I might be OK.
No.
I can't...
Don't go this way.
Please.
Yep, there you go.
Oh my God!
Holy... Thank God I was against the wall.
Is it in here?
There we go.
I thought so.
Edward, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you, Edward.
Happy birthday!
Gosh, I heard their steps though.
That's why I didn't go.
Thank goodness.
Little Mark 2, you are so goofy looking.
It's me, snake.
Metal Gear?
Except he's got smooth moves.
Do you remember Rex?
And look how goofy and cute it is.
It's just like those dogs.
OK
Goodies What's that?
We got the solid eye baby!
You can't see but mine says Mito Eye System.
Jump!
Why did you have to make it the left eye though?
Why did you have to become Solidus?
Yeah!
Those are our allies.
Well, they will be.
Right?
I have to make friends.
Left eye dominant maybe?
You shoot out of your right eye typically.
Yeah, but he can still see through it.
Otacon, I love you.
You are so good to me.
Yeah
It's a little...
The fact that Otacon is moving this and making it so moe...
I want him to be a Vtuber.
OK
OK OK Literally
I'm on my toes and my heels.
Alright!
We got the Mark 2 Pistol.
We got the Operator.
We got the Solid Eye.
Blue text represents an ally.
Closer color to red represents a hostile target.
OK!
Metal Gear Mark 2!
Equip it from the item window.
Yeah, we can like kind of just send him out and have him scope things for us.
A schlep?
OK That way?
That way.
OK.
Hold on.
I'm gonna send out... Here I wanna show you guys.
Let's try him out.
Sir, I release you!
No.
Wait.
Yeah.
Release you!
Mark 2!
It's got a lot of other functions as well.
Here we go!
Oh god!
Mark 2, get out of there!
He's gone forever.
Mark 2!
No, he's fine.
We got him still.
We got our Solid Eye.
He wants us to go this way cause Otacon hates us a bit.
Let's do... I can't remember if it's this Act 1 or Act 2.
I think it's Act 2 where we need to go completely non-lethal, but...
I'll do it here anyway just in case.
Rip the Mark 2.
No!
And we can get more Octocamo if we do that.
Who's our buddies?
Assault Rifle.
Oh shoot!
How do I... There we go.
Hello?
Can I move?
Can I... Oh I have to... Oh my god.
My hand.
I took that guy out.
I'll take him out too.
Oh my god.
It's like so many... Oh!
It's so many things that I have to push to like...
How do you hear that?
How do you even hear that?
You don't.
Like don't even pretend that you hear that.
Oh it's locked on.
How do I stop that?
Oh my god.
Sorry.
I'm still... OK.
Basically, so you have... Why am I... OK there we go.
You have to press triangle.
Why am I like a dog?
Snake what are you doing?
Get a snake!
Guys, I don't know how I did this.
Oh there we go.
OK.
Apparently when you're lying down and you press...
Those are allies?
I can't tell.
Oh my god.
It's such craziness here.
OK.
Lock on.
Ass.
I'll get these guys too.
Why not?
That guy has a helmet on.
But I think I still got him.
These guys are the allies-ish.
I think I have to earn their trust first.
But let's just...
I'm helping you guys out.
Where are they shooting from anyway?
There's just bullets everywhere.
Shoot this way snake.
Do that.
Shoot that guy.
Now I can't see him.
Just kidding.
Shoot these guys.
Shoot that guy.
Shoot... Oh that's not a guy.
Oh now it's on fire!
OK get that guy.
OK I'm gonna keep going.
Anyway good luck everybody else.
Collect all their weapons and I can...
Yeah I got your back buddy!
I got your back buddy!
I got your back...buddy!
You got my back?
I got your back.
And then I left.
How do I do that?
Open the item.
Oh there we go.
Night vision.
Suddenly it's... Oh my god.
This isn't buddy though.
This is buddy.
Right?
It's buddy.
This is buddy.
I can't see anything.
What is... Oh binoculars.
This is buddy.
I think they're buddy.
Gosh he's coming.
I'm buddy!
I'm buddy.
OK I'm buddy.
See it's blue.
It's blue.
We're buddy.
I'm buddy.
I haven't killed anybody.
I haven't killed anybody!
Why are you sniffing me up and down?
What do you mean again?
I'm buddy!
I'm buddy.
Full on ration.
I'm too good at this game.
I forgot the... What's it called?
The solid eye has a battery life.
I think I went in through the wrong entrance, buddy.
Buddy, I gotta go back from where... Oh, it's just me.
I'm buddy.
I can't see anything.
There we go.
That is the right way!
How do I get through?
Get the rations.
I'm full on rations.
It told me.
Wait, hold on.
It's gotta be the right way.
Unless there's another entrance over here.
Yeah, see?
It's fine.
I can get more stuff.
There we go.
Move the camera.
Where are we going?
This is just an adventure.
I'm venting.
This way.
What's over here?
I don't think I'm in the right spot.
Ammo.
I think I just went in a big old circle.
I'm going back in there.
Maybe I'm silly.
But we got another weapon, which is good.
Because you sell those.
It is in here.
It's in here.
A great circle, perhaps?
Oops.
You're certainly silly, but you may not be wrong.
I can't remember.
It's okay.
It's just Minto.
We're buddy.
We are buddy.
Why are you so silly?
Militiaman.
He's looking me up and down.
Don't be jealous of my bod.
Come on.
I'm going.
What is that?
I got god.
Wait.
Not here.
No, no, no.
Is there a way to scroll?
Come on, snake.
Your butt can fit through there.
I promise.
Keep using the night vision.
Clearly.
They're like, you can't figure it out without the night vision, you dummy dum-dum.
Oh, I'm buddy.
I'm buddy, I'm buddy, I'm buddy.
Hey!
Oh, wait.
You're...
You are...
You're yellow.
He is not buddy.
But the chicken...
Do you think he'll attack me?
Oh, hello.
It's me.
You're not going to attack with the chickens around.
He's going to look me up and down and then he's going to realize buddy.
Blue.
Blue buddy.
Why does everyone hate me?
What have I done?
Why do they all recognize me but have such a disdain for me?
These poor chickens, I can't, they're so sad.
No, I'm sorry chickens.
Everybody recognizes me but they like think I suck.
What if I give him... How do I give them food?
How do I give him like something to... How do I make him like my real, real buddy?
Is this the usual room?
Oh no.
Drop it, let's see.
Items.
Oh, sorry, I pressed circle like this is a JP game instead of X.
It doesn't count as a ration, does it?
No, all items.
Noodles.
Okay, bowl of instant noodles.
How do I drop it?
You hand it to him.
Here we go.
Hey buddy!
He's in love with me now.
All it takes... Everybody bonds over the noodles, you know?
Everybody bonds over the noodles.
Let's go!
You want some noodles?
Not the usual room.
Don't send me back.
If you win, that means you are a good chicken.
I'm buddy.
Oh what?
You selfish!
Oh my god and then he runs off!
That was not meant for you!
Oh my god.
It hurts.
Sometimes the... Please.
Sometimes it's so sensitive, you know?
See, you can't get too close to it.
You just gotta be enough close to it to be able to get on top of it.
You know what I mean?
You have to be walking at it.
There we go.
The pizazzamine!
Hello
ally buddies.
I gotta get my solid eye back up.
It's that way but what was over...
I got a compress.
Oh hi!
I'm buddy!
This guy is literally dying and I'm just like...
Hello.
Why do they hate me?
Oh no!
These are locked but we can sell them.
Ew.
Stinky.
Everybody in here is smelly.
Me too now.
Is there anything in here?
Just my hands.
Check my weapons.
Snakes feel good.
My weapons.
What about them?
Nasty.
You got anything else that I can have?
Oh hell yeah.
We got a grenade.
What about you?
If only this were MGS5 then we would actually get stinky.
Oh I'm full.
Bye bye.
You guys okay?
Yeah, you guys are okay.
You guys are okay.
Thank you.
Are you winning?
Yeah.
I'm exploring a little bit.
Oh, this one is green.
Hello.
Hi.
I'm really...
Oh my god.
Just kiss already.
He likes me.
Oh.
Okay.
What is that?
Oh, that's the...
That's the wings that that one...
You felt the rope.
The other guy just noticed.
He has no survival instincts.
Yeah, it's the wing of one of the beauties.
Why do you all hate me?
I'm going.
I'm taking your stuff a little bit first.
It's flapping.
I know.
It's so creepy.
Wow.
I don't...
Maybe I just didn't notice that before.
They need noodles?
You're not you when you're hungry.
Come here.
You're with us?
Why are you so surprised?
Hold on.
Wasn't there... or maybe...
Oh, okay.
I got something else.
I feel like I'm gonna have to find a different spot for me to hang out in.
We're almost out of noodles.
Oh, this is a wall.
Okay.
They're green.
They're green now.
Did you notice that?
Look at my footprints everywhere.
Alright.
It's me.
Oh, okay.
He doesn't care.
Me?
Oh, his little heart.
I don't have an enemy gun.
I mean, I do, but I'm gonna sell it for...
for big money.
That's what I'm gonna do.
They're friends now.
Yeah.
That's locked.
Playboy magazine!
I cannot believe it's actually listed as a Playboy.
That's crazy.
The product placement in this game is absolutely wild.
Bonkers.
Bonkers wild.
Oh, this guy is yellow.
Hello!
Maybe I'm more stealthy than I think.
Like, I can just stand here.
Hello.
Like, if they weren't my friends, I think I'd be able to get away with it.
You know?
Hello.
Oh, I don't think they care actually.
I'm not important enough for them to even greet me.
This is so sad.
Our buddies!
Yeah, it's me.
Okay, so this is where we were on the other side.
Perfect.
Try and conceal his gun.
No!
I kicked the can.
That's so messed up if I was trying to sneak through here or kick the can.
Full ration.
I would have...
I got a petrol bomb.
I would have made all sorts of noise and they would have gotten me.
I would have gotten got.
I missed a cardboard box?
Wait, where at?
Here?
No less ration.
I missed a box?
Where at?
Unless you mean all these cardboard boxes?
Also a militia outfit?
Wait, where?
I thought I saw everything.
Right over here, right?
No.
It's a box under a vent system.
We already have them because new game plus.
Wait, let me check my items.
Are you sure?
I don't think so.
I really don't think I have much of anything.
I have... Oh no, I do.
I have a box.
I have a drum can.
But I do not have an outfit.
I do not have an outfit.
Arsenal.
Oh, this is the compress.
Neat.
Outfit is in camo.
Cool.
Change costume.
Check the face camo?
Oh no, I might have the beauties.
Oh no.
Oh god.
No, I'm not.
Oh my god.
It's so over for me.
Oh my god, it's so...
I look so dumb with her.
I love Fem Raiden.
Okay, this might be the worst one.
They all look so... They all look so dumb with the neck.
Like the neck pieces make it look so awful.
Oh, these are spoilers?
Yeah, kind of.
I cannot equip the face camo.
Oh handsome.
Handsome lad right here.
It's just spoilers on future bosses.
Sorry guys.
Oh my gosh, his...
The pixels define his cheekbones so well.
Depends on what you count as a spoiler.
I think that... Oh my gosh, we can watch Sunny, I forgot.
I consider story...
Story spoilers more as spoilers than like what kind of... Like, you know, than boss spoilers.
But I understand that.
If someone's just like, I don't want to know about anything until it happens.
You know.
Sunny nanny cam.
What is she looking for?
She's trying to learn how to twerk.
Don't do that, Sunny.
You're too pure.
Actually, oh, she's learning the gravure poses.
She's reading the magazines and she's learning the poses.
Sunny!
Sunny, stop!
Sunny, wait until you're older!
Oh my god, that one is...
She's the cutest ever.
Oh...
It's like watching a puppy.
She's the cutest thing.
Oh gosh.
I love Sunny.
Best girl, so true.
There she goes.
But yeah, I don't have the camouflage for the militia.
So where can I get that?
Oh wait, I'm such an idiot.
Yes I do.
It says ME, Middle East.
I do have it.
It's so messed up looking.
Oh, it was this way.
Mint East one.
You have other weapons.
Oh my god, do I have so much?
I just don't realize it.
Wait, what else do I have?
I forgot.
Wait, what is she doing?
She's gaming.
Oh my god!
Wait, some of these are locked.
It kept everything.
Spoiler.
But I feel like I'm gonna be using...
I don't have very many tranquilizing stuff.
So I feel like I'm gonna be using...
We'll put this in too.
ID locked.
I have to unlock them.
I don't really need that though.
I feel...
Bleh, boy.
The babes of the world's top PMCs.
Hideo Kojima interviewed.
I can't read what it says in the red part though.
Something or...
Nano...
Beast?
The truth behind...
Something drone.
Oh, here we go.
The games and beyond.
Hideo Kojima interviewed.
Nano boost or nano bust.
The truth behind nano drone.
The best FPSs of the year.
Can you believe we used to pay for these things?
He's pirating his games.
7th circle.
Sadistic joke becomes prime time sensation.
Entertainment for men and Minto.
Staring at one of these in a first person view...
Curiously raises Snake's psyche.
Okay, we'll definitely have that on the...
In the bar then.
We'll have that.
We'll have that out.
Okay.
Alright, let's go.
Oh, golly.
If I put it down, I can grab it back.
I can pick it back up, I'm pretty sure.
Raises something for sure.
Don't say that.
Oh, I should have changed the face.
Oh, I have you.
Oh no, Drebin forgot to change the face for the...
Oh, monkey!
It's a fucking monkey!
The monkey with the caffeine addiction.
Oh...
I should have changed the face, I'm sorry.
Oh, Drebin.
Talking monkey.
He comes in peace.
Hey, hey, hey.
You can't just say that.
You're not him.
You are not him.
Drebin is such a silly character.
The little head bob, I know.
It's too good.
He's like...
I take ID guns like the PMCs use and make some mods.
Then you can use them without having to match IDs.
The music is too good.
In other words, I'm a gun launderer.
You can call me Drebin.
Drebin!
Yeah, they use that for all of us.
I have you.
All over the world.
Not that I ever met any of them personally.
Me, I'm Drebin number 893.
You ain't a registered PMC employee.
Are you?
You need a guy like me.
Judgment, guys.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Consider it a welcome gift.
Truly dystopian ID locked guns.
I know, right?
It's crazy.
I forgot how bad graphics were back then.
Are you talking about Steak's face?
Gosh, these dang PS3 graphics are horrible.
The graphics are actually just so good.
You can see the velvety-ness of Drebin.
Like his tie, you know.
It's crazy.
He's nerding out.
Noobs.
Pew!
I like the camo pants and the blazer top.
I'm in charge of production control.
So I get my hands on all the ID chips before they even register.
Have a sit.
Indirect kissu.
It's a side of AT the public don't see.
From the looks of it, you ain't with any state army.
But you ain't exactly green either.
Mm-mm.
Chill.
Talk to me, Otacon.
What's your take on him, Otacon?
Sunny!
Balkans.
How's he pull it off, anyway?
Brain hurts.
Oh.
Hmm.
A little weasel.
Yeah.
I mean...
I'm not asking him out on a date or anything.
It's just business.
No, caffeine addicted monkey!
Don't let him drink another soda!
Oh, I have already.
Hell yes.
Woo!
No romancing, Drebin.
What you got for me?
Drebin893.
Not the vending machine!
Can I buy more sody?
The alien.
lol Oh no.
Scary.
So I have to have nanomachines after nanomachines on top of nanomachines.
Yeah.
Monkey!
lol
Tell me when it's over!
Ok, it's not so bad since it's PS1 Snake.
They work so fast.
Noodles, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
He's got a Lakers 2009 rings?
What the hell?
He's a Lakers fan?
Don't be mean to the monkey!
He's just a monkey.
Why are you so addicted to the soda?
1 hexo, welcome to membership.
Thank you!
System codes are the law now.
And control is essentially absolute.
Paving the way for fat profits, if you're willing to bend the law.
Demand keeps on growing thanks to the war economy.
I sell ID guns to the PMCs and state armies.
And make it guns to terrorist groups and paramilitaries.
And these ID guns can't be sold on the black market.
System's practically a license for us arms dealers to print money.
Privatizing the military has made the PMCs big and bloated.
The fatter the PMCs get, the line between civilian and soldier is gonna get real blurry.
Sooner or later, the whole damn human race is gonna be green collars.
More like, we're all gonna be fighting proxy wars.
That's just a theory.
A game theory.
What eyes?
He's got no eyes.
Thank you.
Bye Driven!
Let's go.
Bye monkey!
Tank monkey.
Man, the war economy.
And we're back outside, baby.
I don't think I need my disguise, honestly.
I think I'm fine with the camo.
Skyline, welcome to membership!
Thank you!
Hello?
Thank you, thank you!
I think then you can make money in different places.
Open a lemonade stand.
World peace?
Can you imagine?
Sell ice cream.
Yeah.
Why don't we invest money into robot anime girls instead?
Make love.
Not war.
The Driven menu item.
Make the cat girls real.
I see.
Rat patrol.
Rat patrol, you say.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Monkey.
I get that.
Because, yeah, if you need a weapon you can literally just buy it from him.
So I do get that.
But that's also what they do in MGS5 and nobody complains about that.
Holy moly!
I have 200,000 DP.
1,000,000 DP!
We'll be able to get the big bucks, baby.
Look at all this.
5,000,000!
For the bandana!
Then I would have unlimited ammo.
Ok, we're gonna save up 5,000,000 DP.
What's this one?
Is this just stealth camo?
Ok, we're gonna save up 10...wait, that's...
5,000,000!
We're gonna save up 10,000,000 DP.
This is the first and so far only MGS I managed to beat entirely non-lethally.
Really?
Receipt?
Oh, thank you for your patronage.
You're welcome.
Ok, 10,000,000!
What else we got?
Suppressor, suppressor, suppressor, suppressor.
Oh, wow.
Oh, lights.
Oh.
Bullets, bullets, bullets, bullets, bullets, bullets, bullets...
Not looking at those.
Gosh.
If you couldn't tell, yes, this is New Game Plus, so...
I do have everything.
Alright.
I'm gonna save real quick.
No, I can save over the old data.
Play the iPod?
What do you wanna hear?
I'll play my favorite song.
Hold on, it's saving.
My favorite song.
Music.
Wait, how do I?
Scroll.
Oh, scroll.
I forgot it's the iPod.
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait, there we go.
I have to hold it down.
Song.
We have Calling to the Night?
Hold on.
Song!
Look at Sunny.
Oh, my God, you're right.
Eee!
Look at her!
This is the best game ever.
This is the best game ever!
It really has everything.
It's so great.
I wish I had a full version.
Find a karaoke.
I would love to sing.
Sorry, Minto, but my new Oshi is Sunny.
I don't blame you.
This is gonna become a Sunny fan channel.
I'm gonna start doing just Sunny clips.
This song is so cute.
Okie.
The only way across is straight through.
Straight through.
I wish I could still listen to it and have my... Ok, hold on.
Oh, you can get Taiga there.
Oh yeah, let's change from the... Let's change from this song.
I wonder why I can't equip this.
Let's just do the Octocamel.
Ok, I'll be careful.
I hear people dropping things.
Do you hear that?
It's so crazy.
I don't think I can.
Ok.
Everybody's dying.
Everybody's dying and here I am.
Oh, I have full ration.
I'm listening to the happiest music.
Nevermind, we're not going that way.
Just kidding.
Or maybe we can.
I don't know actually.
I'll take your stuff.
Ok, you guys like that?
Alright, now I need to know where I'm going.
I think I do go this way though actually.
Yeah, I'm lost.
Snake.
Snake, go up.
It's through here.
Oh no.
Oh shoot.
There's more stuff.
Oh, this is the guy that I tried to get earlier.
Oh, it's just ammo.
It's fine.
It's
fine.
Oh gosh, oh gosh.
Yeah, I don't sound Willis anymore.
Don't worry.
This is friend.
Oh no.
I'm not going to lie you guys.
This is unironically what Paz sounds like when she shits.
I wanted to rename Paz Johnny.
Because this is actually what she sounds like when she's using the litter box.
Oh, the cat.
Yeah, my cat.
What else did you think about?
My cat.
I already have these, but that's ok.
I thought you meant Paz.
Yeah, Paz is my cat.
It's clean.
Snake, I still wouldn't.
Snake, I wouldn't.
Snake, no.
Snake.
It probably reeks in there.
Don't do it.
No, don't.
Not your head.
Snake.
Sorry I'm late.
I didn't know they made a prequel for MGSV.
When does Venom show up?
He's my favorite boss.
Stop it.
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the 20 gifted.
Thank you.
What's over in here?
Got it.
I got it.
Oh wait.
Oh, here it is.
Oh, it's the rations.
Gosh, we're getting lots of playboy, huh?
Lucky us.
Ok.
Rendezvous point.
Who is not our friend?
Ok, I can see them.
I'm helping.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, I had to reload anyway.
That was good.
I think I got him.
Maybe I didn't, actually.
I think I got him that time.
You're welcome.
I am.
Well, you know.
I'm doing my best.
Oh gosh, there's really big guys coming up.
You're welcome.
But like, that's a whole ass tank.
I can't put that to sleep.
Hey, stop pushing me out of the way.
You're going to ruin my shot.
Oh, I don't think I got that guy.
Where are they?
Everything is sold.
You can try.
True.
Where are they shooting from anyway?
I can't even see.
Oh my God.
They
are going sicko mode.
Oh my God.
I'm trying to help.
Oh, that's not...
I know.
I think I got him.
Then why did you send me this way, Otacon?
You think I could grenade it?
Nevermind.
You don't need me.
I got this.
Me?
Are you talking to me?
Oh my God.
I need to go that way.
Like, kind of.
Oh shoot.
Which way?
Is this a... Can I go through here?
Can I crawl under this?
Oh damn, I can.
I'm kind of going the opposite way, but...
Actually, this should help me get around, I think.
Hello, friend.
See?
They love me.
I'm helping you.
Oh, shoot.
I'm helping you guys.
Charge?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, buddy.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I mean, you can shoot them.
You're welcome.
Who?
Who saw me?
Wait, actually, who saw me?
Window?
Oh, that guy up there.
Oh my God.
Why is this so dramatic?
Oops.
You're welcome.
What do you mean?
It's the... It's the, like, famous ass grab that everybody does.
Oh, there.
I see him.
Sorry.
I'm helping you.
I got him.
Yeah, you're welcome.
I don't know where else they're shooting from.
I'm running with you guys.
See?
I'm such a good helper, aren't I?
Who's shooting?
Oh, that window.
I see him.
I got his ass.
Oh, no I don't.
Oh, I do?
I got his ass.
You're so welcome.
I'm such a helper.
One guy dropped his gun over here.
I hear them snoring.
These lazy bones over here.
Oh, there it is.
I watched him drop this earlier.
It's a new gun even.
Lucky me.
Do I have to go around this way?
I think.
I think I go past the...
Go past the tank.
Any baddies?
Where's my friends?
Oh, shoot.
That's not a friend.
That's a foe.
Let's see.
How do I...
Oh, shoot.
Why does it only get upset when I'm here?
What do you mean?
No!
Oh, shit.
I'm so in trouble.
I'm leaving.
Maybe that is my friend.
Oh my God.
No!
I wanted to add my drum can and my box.
I forgot to add those earlier.
There we go.
Snake is getting upset.
He's getting angry.
I'm just on normal difficulty.
I like to have fun with the game.
Look, we're so close to the rendezvous point.
It's literally right there, you guys.
I'm not toast.
My camo index?
I don't even know what it is.
Oh, it's negative 16.
Okay, we're at 65.
I don't know how we're still alert.
I don't know how they're still seeing me.
Oh, shoot.
They're still seeing me.
Oh, there's a guy right there.
Oh my God.
I can get his ass.
There we go.
See?
I don't know where anyone else is, though.
See, we're fine.
I just gotta keep going.
Bro's staring at you, I know.
I don't remember how to reload in this game.
Equip, unequip doesn't work.
Anyway.
He's barely stressed.
We're so fine.
That's like me on a daily average.
50% stress.
Don't worry about it.
I think I got him.
Hey friend, is he still alive?
He's moving.
Maybe not so much anymore.
I got him.
Oh, what do I do?
Otacon, where do I go?
Otacon!
Over here, maybe.
Is that it?
Is that another guy?
Oh no, I don't see anyone else.
I don't see anyone else.
Maybe in the windows?
There's like guns everywhere.
There's just shooting everywhere.
Hello friends, I'm coming in.
Let me in, let me in, let me in, let me in.
I'm here to help.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm here to assist.
I'm reloading.
I have no more bullets.
Ok, bye.
Good luck everybody else.
But not before I earn more money.
Oh, shoot the door shut.
Anyway...
Why am I such a big deal?
There's enemies everywhere.
Nice assist boss, you're welcome.
I don't have any more ammo actually.
You guys can't see it because I'm blocking it.
I have to find a good place for my head.
But no, I actually don't have any more ammo.
As you can see.
It's ok.
Alright, where's the poop squad?
Sorry, rat squad.
Ranch ramp.
Aren't there guys in here or am I crazy?
Isn't this place crawling with people?
Oh, it's not showing up on the...
On the map, the mini map.
Maybe we're ok.
Locked weapon, projectile.
Can I get over here?
Come on snake.
Jump over it.
Jump over it with your hands.
Hit circle.
Thanks guys.
I was trying to figure out how to reload earlier.
Thank you.
Ok, I don't think I can go in there.
I give up.
That...
Wait, how do I zoom?
Nope.
I don't know.
Use the mark too?
We're just gonna sacrifice him like that?
Gassy.
Oh, I went in normal mode again.
Thank you.
Nice.
Alright.
Ok.
This way.
So, let's go through...
Let's go upstairs.
Was it here?
There is a stairs.
No, not downtown.
Here we go.
Upstairs.
Mark too can grab those.
Wait, no way.
How so, I wonder.
Still being guarded.
I did not see that one.
Oh, Snake are you...
A triangle.
Ok, I didn't see that one at all.
I'm so sorry Snake.
I'm so sorry.
Sorry buddy.
I didn't see it.
I'm really sorry.
Ok, here we go.
Alright.
Mark too.
Deploy!
I know, I know.
I'm gonna get him.
I'm not gonna use my solid eye.
Triangle.
Yoink!
Ok.
Nice.
They are recharging battery now.
That is how it works, right?
It recharges like when I'm not using it.
I don't think there is any people in here.
So...
Not yet at least.
Oh.
Ok.
Any other traps in here?
Speaking of bathroom, I gotta go soon.
To the bathroom I mean.
Not leave.
Just bathroom stuff.
Oh, can't open that.
Alright.
Onwards.
Onwards, forwards.
Ok, hold on.
Before we do that.
God!
I just turned the camera, please!
Holy cannoli!
Oh my gosh!
I didn't even move!
Alright, Otacon.
You could have detected enemy.
Yeah.
Ok.
Fell for the ramen trap.
Then what do you want me to do?
You guys keep an eye on Snake while I go to the little ghost room, ok?
Storm it with your face.
Ok,
I just gotta go pee real quick.
I'll be fast.
Ok.
B, R, B.
I'm back.
I'm back, sorry.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Thank you for the 50 Gets.
Thank you.
I wanted to go say hi to my cat.
Alrighty.
How do I get through this again?
Otacon, give me a hint.
I don't remember.
Tell me.
Welcome back.
I'm back.
Look at that old Johnny.
Wait, so...
Yeah, see, my battery is now full.
Awesome.
I'm gonna figure out a good... Actually, let me... I think I can place myself.
I'm gonna be a little bit of like a...
There.
I'm just gonna put myself here so that I'm not in the way of the interface and also not the subtitles.
There we go, that should be...
Should be ok for now.
I'll figure out something for future streams.
Floating head Minto, yeah?
Ok.
So, later.
Ok, then.
Where do I go then, Otacon?
I'm a little confused guy.
I'm just a little confused man.
Ok, I can't run like that so much or Snake gets upset.
His little psyche goes down because he's old.
Oh, we can go upstairs again.
Yeah, let's go up.
Senior!
Thank you so...
Much further!
20?
Thank you!
I almost got it.
I almost got hit.
I saw it at the last second.
Look how cute he is!
Oh my god, it's too cute.
It's too cute the way he hops up the stairs.
You see that?
Too cute!
Is there any other ones?
Yeah!
I'm looking.
I'm perusing.
I'm gathering intel.
This thing is so freaking loud.
Dual flip!
Another one!
I'm gathering intel.
Yeah, we're...
I never knew about that.
Oh my gosh, he can knock too.
You are so clever.
I never used Mark 2 before.
Honestly, like when I played before.
I didn't use it much at all.
So, this is all kind of new for me too.
Anything in here?
That I can grab and then we'll run around and let the battery recharge.
Wait.
Oh no, nevermind.
Just kidding.
I think we're mostly okay.
Somebody is baking cookies.
Where do you see that?
Sorry, I'm going a little... I'm like zooming around with him because I'm trying to like just...
I'm only trying to...
Okay.
We'll bring him back.
What was I saying?
I don't remember.
And now we can use him.
Our little guy.
I don't think I saw anything else in these rooms.
Let's go check that back area that I...
Oh, we didn't get to go back here either.
Careful.
Easy snake.
Wait.
Right there!
This game still looks amazing.
It's insane, right?
It's actually so crazy.
I say that about honestly like all the Metal Gear games.
Hold up.
I guess the only thing that you could say is...
The only one you could argue against is MGS1, but come on.
I would still argue for it.
All things considered.
How do I use the ration?
Press OK button.
There we go.
I
don't know what that was!
I don't know what that was!
Windows!
You're scaring me.
I wish there was a first person view.
Sometimes in this game at least.
I know that there is one if I use the solid eye, but...
It doesn't feel quite the same.
OK.
Oh, here we go.
I think that's another ration.
Okey dokey.
Onwards.
I hear flies.
I hear bugs.
Smelly stinky.
We're outside again.
Alright, this way.
I see another one, so I'm going to send out Mark 2 again.
Follow the rat.
No!
Sorry.
What the hell?
Slow, steady, grab.
Nice.
Actually...
Hello?
This is... What?
How far can he go though?
I don't want him to get out of range.
I got... What was that?
I don't know what that was.
I think it was maybe a book?
So crazy!
Are we going to see a girl working out?
That would be so funny.
Alright, come back to me.
We can't, we can't... Or can we crawl through here?
I guess we can.
We are big enough for it.
That's fine, we went through.
We went through, we're fine.
Any bombs?
Nope.
I'm sneaking, but my cheek claps alert the guards.
That's...
Is that a bomb?
This view makes me think of that one crawling ghost from Fatal Frame 3.
Ok.
God, Snake, stop being so lazy, you lazy pants.
I got so much noodle.
We're getting so much stuff.
This is crazy.
Here we are!
Rat Patrol!
No spoilers you guys.
Come on, come on.
Let him introduce himself.
I like the Foxhound patch.
Ok,
now we know who it is.
Johnny!
Holy, my ears.
My goodness.
A lady!
Bald guys!
What are you trying to say, madam?
Oh my god!
Oh my god, get off of him!
The knee is the weapon.
I wouldn't try anything funny if I were you.
Oh no, she's hot.
Fox.
Miss Meryl!
She lived!
She lived after...
After even I killed her.
Nope.
That's so rude.
Yeah.
Does she still wiggle while she walks?
Absolutely.
And why do you still have your guns up?
Do you literally not just see us having a friendly conversation?
You can have this back.
Johnny, our little Himbo shitter.
What's wrong with you?
Go away.
Just leave.
Get
out of here Snake before...
Before the explosion!
Jeez, Johnny.
Just like my cat.
Liquid.
A woman?
Who is that?
Oh, we have bad eyesight because we're old.
Nevermind.
He's such a grumpy old fart now.
Oh.
That's such a stupid...
Oh buddy.
Johnny.
Why do they call him Akiba though?
Get this guy some Pepto.
Okay, Akiba.
She's so dumb with him.
Oh boy.
No.
Wow.
Snake at this age, with this look, is what I feel Gen Z actually thinks 40 year olds look like.
Because what?
Meryl would be like mid-20s.
No, sorry.
They're about 30s now.
Early 30s.
Not wrong.
Snake is late 30s.
He was about 31?
In...
Shadow Moses.
Meryl is 25 years.
27?
25, 27?
Oh my god, she was 18 in...
Here, we'll watch the cutscene first.
She was like 18 in Shadow Moses.
Not dumb.
That's crazy.
Sweat?
Crazy.
Okay.
They're gonna know when you're dorking it.
How much sweat do you sweat?
Is that Meryl at the top?
Why does her face look like that?
They did her so dirty with this picture.
What the hell?
It's like some guy put a wig on and said he's Meryl.
No way.
Meryl was sick that day so Johnny put on a wig and said it's him.
A commodity.
I think Minto and Johnny are made for each other.
I don't hate Johnny.
Johnny is proof that you can shit your pants and somebody will still love you.
Johnny should give us all hope.
And finding love.
He's our IPS King.
Yeah.
SOP.
She says la li lu le lo.
Really?
Johnny appeals me too much.
There he is.
Army special operations.
What was the last one?
Command?
Thank you.
No.
Such a big heart.
Johnny looks the same.
I think it's Evan Obey.
I think she was absent that day.
Yeah!
Break stuff!
Give me something to break!
Some nanomachines kicking in good baby.
Why are you still calling him uncle?
You're still calling him Colonel.
He's your father.
As far as I'm concerned, we're still uncle and niece.
I will never forgive that womanizing piece of shit.
He doesn't know.
Yeah, Meryl is so cute in this game.
She looks like a young boss, you know?
His new wife's about my age.
I hear she's even got a kid.
It's as if he's given up on making up with his own daughter.
And men.
Men!
Selfish, egotistical pigs.
You tell him!
What is it?
So good.
Hmm.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh!
Oh no!
The frogs!
These guys are serious business.
Yeah.
That's how I feel.
Oh crap!
Were you being followed?
This frog is such an egotistical man.
True.
Oh buddy!
You just said so.
You just claimed fault.
Nobody thought so until you said it.
Oh!
No!
It wasn't my fault!
I swear!
Oh man!
Look I...
Dumbass!
We're moving out!
Meryl, where's Liquid?
At a camp up ahead.
He's so extreme.
If we're still alive.
Okay.
Alright.
I think I still have to be non-lethal here.
The MacBook.
Alright.
I think I do?
I'm not sure.
It does count?
Okay.
Oh gosh!
The frogs!
Oh god!
They're so cool.
But they're so scary.
But they're so cool.
But they're so scary!
Turning down the volume a little bit.
Okay.
A little anxious guy.
Aww.
Woman unit!
Alright.
I'm going with you guys.
Why do I...
No, no, no, no.
Hold on.
Grenade?
I'm not hiding at all.
I'm kind of like just way out in the open.
Here they come.
More?
Where are they?
Oh, they're up here.
I'm putting them to sleep.
Don't worry.
They'll fall asleep in like two seconds.
I don't think I can...
I don't think I can be non-lethal here.
God, they're good.
Okay, I took that one out.
Hell yeah.
Money, money, baby.
Wait, hold on.
Because I'm trying to...
So basically I'm trying to get the solar gun.
And I can't remember...
Yeah, Sunny is making eggs.
I can't remember if I...
Can do non-lethal here or not.
I don't have it in my inventory because I never got it before.
I don't think.
Solar...
Real gun.
I don't have to be non-lethal the whole game.
Yeah, I don't have it.
I think this portion counts.
I'm pretty sure this portion counts.
Sorry guys, I should've read it again to confirm.
I know it's like at least up until Meryl's...
Up until you meet Meryl, but I'm not sure if it's this whole act or not.
I think it's up until act 2 that I have to be non-lethal, so...
Yeah, just letting you know.
I'll just continue.
I have to be at least.
I don't think they have to.
Here we'll just...
Where are they?
Oh, they're up there.
Headshot!
Oh, damn.
Oh, god!
Scared the hell out of me.
I'm equipping my racket.
Ow, ow, stop!
I got you.
Oh, ok, they're gone.
Where'd they go?
Oh, you're over here?
From behind!
Oh, that's kind of crazy.
I can't... I can't see.
When your big ass is in the way!
Oh, my god.
I totally hit you for sure.
I'm going.
I'm with you guys.
Move, Johnny.
Oh, what did you give me?
What did you give me, Johnny?
You're so sweet.
Oh, thank you.
Excuse me.
Oh, my god.
Grenade!
I can't.
Freaking...
Oh, my god.
Johnny, get out of the way.
No!
I should have taken the shot.
There's so many of them!
Oh, my god.
Sleepy babies.
Thanks, John.
Can I pierce them?
Everybody just said only do head shots.
So that's why I figured I only can.
I don't know if I can... Oh, shoot.
Oh, my god.
I can't remember how to... Oh, my god.
Ouch.
Is it... Which button is it to look up?
I don't wanna have to...
Body shot counts?
Oh, okay.
Well, he's gone now.
I'm like doing nothing, but that's okay.
Oops.
I have to have good aim first.
Where are you?
Show up.
I think I got them.
Oh, there they are.
Hello.
I got them.
We're good.
Yeah, I got them.
Yeah, baby.
Why aren't we going forward?
I'm following you guys.
I'm following Meryl.
She's hotter.
Nevermind.
She went the wrong way.
Good job.
Clear.
Take their stuff.
Get some money.
This is Splinter Cell.
Excuse me.
I too follow hot women.
Alright.
Let's go, Meryl.
I know you're a stealth game fan.
Have you played Assassin's Creed?
I have not played Assassin's Creed.
I also don't like stealth games.
Truthfully.
I'm just in the open.
What?
You want me to go?
Fine.
I'm sacrificing myself.
She's sacrificing herself.
I can't see anything.
Johnny, come on, buddy.
Come on.
Be strong, buddy.
Be strong.
I can't.
Be strong, buddy.
You got this.
Why can't I see through the...
Oh my god.
Ugh.
Hold on.
I'm doing so...
I don't know why my...
There it is.
I think I had the auto-aim on and it was messing me up.
There we go.
One down.
They're arguing over there.
I'm just not gonna listen to them.
Why do I keep having auto-aim?
Oh, I'm pressing square instead of circle.
That's why.
That's my bad.
Stop running!
I think they're down.
And one over.
I got them.
I don't got them.
Well, they'll fall asleep eventually.
Probably.
Like a married couple.
Truly.
Where'd they go?
Oh, there they are.
Dang it.
Don't move.
Are they shooting from down here?
Oh, yes they are.
Somewhere.
Don't hit me, okay?
They're like...
Oh, damn.
I thought I had them there.
Oh, I got them.
I did get them.
Slowly but surely.
We could just keep going.
I'm just saying.
If all we're trying to do is escape, I mean...
We could just keep walking...
It's on me!
Did they all leave?
Hey!
Where'd everybody go?
Oh my god.
What the hell?
You guys!
Oh, good job.
Is that Johnny?
I'm eating bullets.
Oh, that's awkward.
Anyway.
You okay, Meryl?
Nah, she's fine.
You okay too?
Everybody's hiding in corners.
What's going on?
Oh yeah, we can CQC.
What was that again?
Hold on, I got this.
Yeah, you're welcome.
Stop pushing me!
Stop hitting me!
Yeah.
Holy!
Roll out!
MGSV really cleans up the hand to hand combat.
Oh my god.
Johnny.
Oh, Johnny.
Nice.
I'm just gonna grab some stuff real quick.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Anything else in here?
Thank goodness.
That was not a...
Okay, this way.
Wait, what's in here?
There's more stuff.
White phosphorus grenade?
Ready grenade with L1 button.
Well, we won't need it right now.
But, crazy.
And more noodles.
Alright, everybody good?
That's not really good.
I think we should leave.
It's like this door over here, right?
Oh my god.
All we gotta do is run.
All we gotta do is just go.
Bye!
Everybody escape.
Everybody leave.
No?
Okay.
Just me?
Alright.
For someone who loves these...
Emotionally charged messy drama...
Between men who are definitely straight...
You may enjoy Yakuza 0.
I know.
Everybody tells me to play Yakuza.
Everybody telling me to play Yakuza.
Oh, they're down.
Wait.
I got him.
I am.
I'm fine.
You're welcome.
Behind me?
Where?
You are actually...
You're actually throwing off my game.
Meryl!
Oh, I just realized that my line of sight is...
I'm a dummy-dumb.
I'm a dummy head.
Close enough.
There we go.
Actually, close for real.
Elder abuse.
See, this is where I went from the beginning...
and nobody listened to me.
Oh gosh.
Shooting the wall for real.
Meryl just pushed me out of the way.
I wonder literally...
I wonder actually how many I took down...
compared to how many they took down.
The frog doll.
Oh wait.
I guess not.
I need that for the...
gun, don't I?
Did I mess up already?
Did I already mess up?
If I did...
I think we're about to hit...
I think we're about to hit Act 2.
So...
If I messed up...
I can just play it off stream.
Redo the mission off stream.
If it's there in the garage...
you did it non-lethally.
Oh, in here.
Wait.
In the garage, not...
So, in here.
Because this is the garage...
coming up, right?
Wait, why am I suddenly with my M4?
It's trying to sabotage me.
Yeah, down the elevator...
they go into the car garage.
I know what that means.
Okay, yeah.
Gotta pay attention.
Yeah.
Okay.
Meryl Abadie.
I know.
She's so cool in this game.
Everybody becomes so cool...
in this game, except Snake.
But she's always cool.
But you know what I mean.
I think you should actually check.
What do you mean?
You didn't look behind any of the cars.
You just took two glances around...
and said it was fine.
So cool.
Snake is like...
I'm not needed here anymore.
A little overkill, huh?
Don't you think, buddy?
I thought the nanomachines were supposed to calm your anger.
Pain.
Lily.
My team kill Lily.
He said the line.
But...
Your body...
Are you gonna be alright?
Liquid's camp is up ahead.
I'll mark it on your map.
Thanks.
It's so painful.
When old Snake's theme starts playing...
my heart just...
Akiba.
One man's blunder...
can compromise the whole team.
I'm sorry, Commander.
That's Bozo.
You know...
He is grinning ear to ear...
behind that mask.
You know my man...
is glowing behind...
He is just like...
Oh my God.
Yeah, he is teasing.
He is just like...
Otacon.
Okay.
Hotter.
It's true.
Thanks Big Boss.
Thanks.
That geek kid.
Yeah, get with the times old man.
Ah...
Get with the times old man, but...
Look for the doll.
Let's see.
An action figure of one of Liquid's personal frog soldiers.
This rare item can only be found in the Middle East.
This makes a great gift for Sunny.
Nice!
I got it!
Yippee!
Alright, alright, alright.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright, so we gotta get to the...
We got... How much DP do I have now?
I'm just curious.
Not so much.
Hold on, let me...
I think it was about here.
I don't remember.
I'll adjust.
I'll adjust as the stream goes.
Dang.
I think I started with...
200 ,000 and I barely...
210k to 230.
Guys, it's gonna take a lot to get to...
To 5 million!
That one gun is 1 million.
Yeah, this one's 5 million!
I might need to do some grinding off stream.
I might have to do some extreme grinding.
What if I just play the game all over again...
and then catch up to where I am...
with the new NUGA game plus.
And then I'll definitely have enough.
Probably.
Where is it?
Here?
Not that way.
These
are friends.
Now, I don't have to be non-lethal anymore.
Except for...
the...
the bosses.
The boss babes.
And then I'll be good.
Actually...
I thought I...
I think there's only one I did non-lethally.
Or rather, lethally.
I think I did raven...
lethal.
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, I should save.
I should save since we got the frog.
Do the masks count as the dolls?
Dolls?
No.
You can check your figure collection in briefing.
Special actions?
I don't see it in here.
I'll look it up after...
after stream.
Now I don't have to be non-lethal.
I can use my operator at least.
Oh, in between acts.
OK, OK.
I think we are close-ish to the end of...
This is a cutscene.
Oh my god.
Oh my
friends.
My friends taking over the area.
Nevermind.
You good?
Gonna take your stuff?
Go, go, go!
Taking your stuff?
Yeah, I got your back.
Where do I go though?
That's alright.
I'm going to... I don't think we need it so much right now.
I don't wanna get caught-caught, you know what I mean?
So I'm gonna put on this.
I don't wanna cause an alert.
Because they are so dang annoying when you do that.
Hello.
Hello, goodbye.
Can I get him?
I don't know.
Nice work.
You're welcome.
I like that they praise me every time I...
Forget the rifles, they're useless.
Oh my god, buddy, buddy, I almost shot you.
For real.
You're welcome.
God, this guy is... This guy has no instincts at all.
This guy has no instincts, no survival instincts whatsoever.
Holy moly.
He is just...
Yeah.
Reload him.
That's how you do it.
You're welcome.
Oh my god, they're right there.
Oh my god, they're scaring me.
You're welcome.
Watch your back, maybe?
Oh my god.
Why did you do that?
What a dumbass.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I'm trying to...
I swear to god.
Where are we aiming?
Where are we shooting?
This guy right there?
Oh.
Oh, I only shot off his helmet.
Yeah, I don't have to be non-lethal anymore.
I think you're good.
I think your guys are good.
Anybody back here?
No?
I'm going up, baby.
Sorrow is always watching.
Thank you.
I'll put you to sleep.
I didn't know.
I thought you were dead.
Anyway, good night.
Are you asleep?
Oh there he is.
What else is around here?
What else can we grab?
A missile launcher?
Or a javelin?
Good night.
We gotta stop crouch walking so much or Snake is gonna get angry at me.
He's gonna go...
Oh that's my buddy.
Hey buddy.
Good thing I said buddy or else that guy would have been donezo.
His old, old aching back.
Ok, I can't go through there.
My goodness.
Hello buddies.
Where is my operator?
Smooth operator.
You're welcome.
We did it!
Take their weapons!
I'm helping you out.
What are you talking about?
Don't act like you don't know who I am.
I literally shot all these guys for you.
We did it!
But...
I know something.
I'm grabbing their money.
I think that's it.
Everybody's chill now.
The roosters are clucking.
Everything's good.
Yeah, I do know I can trade food and rations and stuff with them.
Alright, cutscene.
I think it's because I'm used to it now.
Because I had to do it all until this time.
It automatically sells the guns.
I'm pretty sure.
Move!
You don't need to be so sneaky, Snake.
It's OK.
They love us.
That's weird.
That...
That's... Why is it doing that?
That's not good.
The dog is laughing.
Crying.
God
damn, girl.
I would leave.
I wouldn't...
That's awesome!
Laughing octopus.
Octopus.
What's the other one?
Wolf?
Crying wolf?
Or I can't remember.
Oh my god.
Can't be.
Ah!
Love that laughing octopus incorporates Solidus' little tentacles.
And then...
Oh my god, they're just...
Their designs are so good.
So good.
No!
My friends!
The framerate.
No, but the PS3 can...
Me every day.
So cool.
So cool!
Oh my gosh.
They're so cool.
I love the beauties.
I love our boss babes.
All our friends are dead.
No, our friends!
No, no, our friends!
Let's take...
Their money.
Aren't there guys now wandering around?
I don't remember.
Actually, I'm pretty sure there are.
But I can still grab all of this.
Maybe make a chunk of change.
Okay, thanks Otacon!
Otacon!
The ice cream truck is back.
Thank goodness.
Oh yeah, I see them.
Or rather...
Okay, hold on.
Let's put on our...
Disguise.
Do auto-Octocamo.
Sometimes I feel like I should just do...
Oh, hello.
Manual...
Octocamo...
Because sometimes it's a little slow, you know?
To adjust.
Hello?
Yeah, there you go.
I ate like so much.
The poor roosters.
They're a little noisy.
Adjust.
I definitely
headshot you!
You bastard!
No, no!
Just kidding.
Nothing.
I hate, I hate everything.
I hate everything.
I hate everything!
I headshot you, you little...
You little piece.
Rage.
It's okay, their weapons are probably poopy numbers.
Oh, wrong way?
Turn around, snake.
Oh my god, I thought...
I thought...
Who's opening the door?
Hey what?
Hey is for horses.
Come in.
Are they going to run into me?
Oh my goodness.
Uh.
Scared me.
Gosh.
Don't get so close.
Are there guys in here?
Come on snake, get over it.
Some good ass camo, I know.
Alright.
Okay, I don't think there's any guys here.
We were at like 80 something.
So we were killing it.
Baby, what's that?
Thank you.
Alright, so we are heading to a camp.
We are heading to...
Let's get this guy.
Damn, oh my...
No we are not!
Okay, he didn't call HQ.
Oh my gosh.
Stinking guy.
Stinking guys!
How many times do I have to teach you this lesson old man?
I think I'm hearing birds and they are freaking me out a little bit.
I'm going to go...
I can't tell what I'm hearing.
Whatever.
Shut up bird.
Where did that other guy go?
Oh, here he is.
Give me your stuff!
Do you have anything?
He has nothing!
Stingy!
Oh, that doesn't open?
Okay.
Alright, I saw a guy up there.
There we go.
Okay.
This place is kind of corralling.
Where am I going anyway?
What do you mean hey?
What did you see?
You didn't see anything.
What do you mean hey?
Scary this place.
This place is so scary.
Is there anybody I can get in here?
Oh my gosh.
Am I able to get this guy's feet?
It's just a mosquito.
Probably.
Oh my god, he would have definitely seen me.
I just realized I don't have a suppressor on this thing anymore or...
I guess it's fine.
Oh my gosh.
Go down.
Go down, snake.
I'm too scared to get up.
Custom parts.
Get in there.
Nevermind.
Her ass is too thick.
More stuff.
Stand up.
I'm trying to make sure we're safe first.
Maybe we're safe.
Maybe we're safer than I thought.
Why does this place feel so empty?
Oh my god.
Golly.
You're just gonna scare me like that?
Nobody.
Oh please, snake.
Please turn around.
Please, snake.
Turn around.
Please.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Who goes there?
Actually, I think that takes care of everybody.
Well, for now.
Until somebody wakes up.
Alright, sneak inside.
Just gonna keep low for now.
We're gonna keep low.
We're gonna keep, you know, low profile.
And all the way over here.
Actually, can we go inside these tents?
What's your definition of empty?
Well, I saw them on the map, but I couldn't see literally anybody walking around.
I don't know.
Look at him go.
Wait, shake.
There we go.
I remember you could do that.
You could shake the controller and it'll...
It'll get rid of the octocamel for cutscenes.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just remembered who's coming up.
I just remembered.
No, don't spoil it.
Don't spoil it, you guys.
Don't spoil it.
Oh my gosh, framerate.
I don't think I noticed the framerate so badly before the previous time I played this.
I think I was just so enthralled with everything.
Which I still am.
Oh my god.
Oh, sorry.
He was up there.
Did you see him?
Oh my god.
Liquid Ocelot!
Get his ass.
Get his ass, snake.
We're working together as a team.
Johnny looks so chill.
Oh my god.
How'd you get this number?
Okay.
You're not here for the fun.
Oh gosh.
He's looking at me.
Never mind.
I thought she was a peace walker.
I didn't kill anything.
I used non-lethal.
He can't blame me.
I didn't kill any of his special units.
The froggies.
Activate it.
Oh my god.
Here it is.
Liquid!
I love that nobody is noticing him.
Just this guy up.
This is how good of a... This is how good of a stealthy person I am.
What's going on?
Oh my gosh.
What if we all had a group?
What if we all had a group IBS attack?
Okay.
3, 2, 1...
Oh no!
Oh my god.
Watch your pants, Johnny.
They love showing his butt, don't they?
Oh my gosh.
Group panic attack!
Who could that mysterious lady be?
Oh my god.
It's mayhem!
Oh god.
Oh my god!
Oh
my god.
They are turning on each other.
Friendly fire!
Oh my god.
Liquid, you freak.
Friendly bonk.
Get out of my way!
I still got... I got my senses, mostly.
Come on, snake.
God, that ass is just so wild.
They unironically ate lunches.
Was that the... What's a lunchly?
Lunchable?
I love those.
Oh my god.
Liquid!
Oh it's the Mr. Beast Lunchable.
I thought they were called the Feastables.
We
are copies of our father, after all.
We are free of the shackles of fate.
Snake, brother.
We are free.
Watch as I surpass my own orgy.
That's real rich, coming from a guy who's not even using his own body.
My favorite
Judy Broi.
Lambda, thank you for the Akasupa.
Naomi!
Oh my god, thank god.
The notification, like... Oh sorry, I forgot to press X, but it's okay.
I don't want to see your face anymore than I have to.
The notification blocked her face for a moment.
It was great.
I hate you so much.
She just talks and riddles.
Also, what were you doing standing beside Liquid?
You treacherous bitch.
Get out of here.
Imagine if Ocelot meowed in MGS4.
It would be a beautiful thing, wouldn't it?
But this is Liquid Ocelot.
Hi Liquid!
He's so cool.
You like my glasses?
Snake!
Fight it!
Get out of here.
I don't want to see your face anymore.
I'm already disgusted.
My day is ruined.
Naomi sucks so much.
I know.
Horrible.
Bye geckos!
Oh Snake!
Snake!
Use the little thing!
Oh my gosh, Johnny is out here being like...
Oh!
Anybody?
Bipedal cows.
Johnny our boy!
Yay!
We end with almost 300,000 DP.
Nice!
Yay!
Special item.
I should have used some more.
Oh my gosh!
You get DP from watching the flashbacks?
Okay.
Time to spam.
Don't be a prisoner of fate.
Also follow your destiny.
What does that even mean?
I know!
She's so horrible!
4.7 million to go baby!
Save the game.
And I think that's act one, right?
Yeah, we did everything.
We're fine.
We got the doll.
Yay!
I think going non-lethal gets you more points.
I think I might just stick with non-lethal then.
I have enough that I... And especially weapons too.
Like I got sniper stuff and everything.
Since I have everything unlocked, I feel like I can do non-lethal pretty much the whole way through.
Maybe I will.
Maybe I'll be kind.
Oh wait!
Mission briefing!
See?
We didn't...
You can also view this mission briefing from the main menu.
See guys?
I was gonna say I think it...
I think it does it.
Okay, now we can check the figures.
2.33 3.77 6.10 9.87 15 The eggs are all messed up.
It's okay, you'll learn how to make them.
84 84
No, she wants to make them sunny side up.
Oh, Olga.
Oh, the picture of Olga.
Who took that picture?
Where did they get that picture?
Sunny!
Oh my gosh, Sunny.
I can't stop saying Sunny.
Sweet little baby.
Eat the eggs, Uncle Hal.
Yeah.
Eat the eggs.
Oh, back from the dead?
Eat the eggs, Snake.
Oh, Sunny.
They're delicious.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, come on.
Oh, she's doing her best.
Are you okay?
Make the mother of all omelettes here, Snake.
I only have ten kills.
It looked like the PMC soldiers all went haywire en masse, too.
I thought it might be a form of ADS, but I didn't detect any aberrations in the EM field.
You were lucky.
Some of those guys' hearts simply stopped.
She was there.
Naomi was at Liquid's side.
Yeah.
I hope you never see her.
I have a knife kill.
How did I get a knife kill?
I did?
CQC uses zero.
I tried.
I literally punched the frog.
What happened?
I punched a frog.
What do you mean zero?
With a cigarette is too much.
How do I save my pig ears?
Otacon, you were stopped.
Everybody is so mean to Sunny for no reason.
Time in cardboard box zero.
I'm really... I'm losing my roots.
Yeah, you tell him.
The eggs are fine.
God, jump scare.
Deepfake Naomi.
How do I switch?
Hold on.
R2 isn't doing anything.
Maybe, hold on.
No, it's not working.
Yeah, we know.
I'm getting money.
Square.
Where is my pig ears?
Where would they be?
This is so cool.
Yeah, thanks for the fox die.
Oh, upstairs?
Ok.
Oh my god!
Is
that a PS3?
Music.
Go Sunny!
She's playing a PSP!
Oh wait!
I just have the one.
Ok, we'll have to get the rest.
We'll have to get the rest.
Oh.
Snake.
As you recall, following the Shadow Moses incident nine years ago, Naomi was detained by the authorities.
But someone arranged for her escape.
Yeah, I hear they added that to my rap sheet too.
What is she playing?
I can hear it.
He must have taken her prisoner himself and forced her to do research in his facility in South America.
Actually, I still cook my eggs the way Naomi teaches Sunny.
I still cook my eggs that way.
Oh yeah.
Oh, battery.
I'm stealing from ourselves.
The address is fake, but Sunny was able to track the message back through its proxies based on access date time stamps and data transfer bars.
This is so cool.
Apparently, the message originated from a server in South America.
I wouldn't exactly call it 100%...
Double Otacon vision.
Colonel, where's Meryl?
Come on, what did I get?
I know she left the Middle East in pursuit of liquid.
I'm sure our sock is on to us by now.
We can't chase that line too far.
Don't worry, I'll do it to everybody.
No!
Snake!
Stand up.
I secured you landing clearance at El Dorado International Airport.
You'll be acting as a UN inspector.
South America.
That's about 20 hours from here.
Am I in the movie?
Can you see me?
Can you see me in the movie?
I'm trying to jump!
Pick me up, snake!
Solo snaking mission.
Oh gosh.
Oh hello!
What a...
The rebels are still pitched in battle against the PMCs.
Uppies!
Uppies sake!
20 hours until we land.
Got it.
I'll have a look at the documents.
Is he gonna kick me?
No, snake, don't kick me.
Okay, snake.
Otacon is like...
Otacon is like, please.
Please, snake, I know you have accelerated aging, but it's not gonna help.
We got a battery.
Face camo!
Otacon face camo!
We got the Buckeye 2 theme!
Oh my gosh, bumping.
That's what I picked up when I bumped into him.
That's hilarious.
Ahem.
Saving.
Let's go, baby!
Alrighty, righty!
Otacon playthrough.
Nobody would want to hurt me.
They'd be like, what an upstanding looking guy.
Oh wait, this is Act 2, right?
Yeah.
Wait a second.
Wait.
Stop it.
I thought I was so used to seeing smoking snake, I didn't realize that we were on Act 2.
Where is he?
No, wait.
I'm just gonna skip and then I'll go straight to the meat.
No, skip!
Skip!
Skip, skip, skip, skip!
Don't read.
Everybody don't look.
Everybody.
Skip, skip, skip, skip.
Oh, this is what I first did.
Maybe in options.
Get me out of here.
Return to main menu.
I don't think I can.
That's okay.
Oh, Sunny.
You guys, look at Sunny.
Look at her down there.
It is options?
It is?
Did I miss it?
It's not here.
What are you talking about?
Oh, it's under save.
Thank you.
There we go.
Okay.
Act 1 done.
I am emotional.
There is a mission briefing, but I guess we did miss the initial ones.
You know.
But maybe it's okay.
Metal gear is lame.
You know, bait used to be believable.
There is also the virtual range.
What's under extras?
Start with save data.
Let's do it with...
We'll do this one.
Bing, bong.
Bing, bing, bing, bing, bong.
The bait has changed.
This theme is so good.
Old Snake theme is so...
Makes me so...
I gotta get my CQC in.
Holy cow!
Does this not count as CQC anymore?
Take him down!
How do I flip him?
Oh, just like that.
There we go.
Maybe that's what they want me to do.
Run towards him and...
Box.
Drum can.
I love when you can briefly see him sitting inside.
And he's got his little... He's not even prepped for action.
He's got his little knees pulled up to his chest.
Like he's like sitting in his fort.
Oh,
it won't let me go.
Gosh, this barrel is nasty.
Hold on.
Sorry, Snake.
I wanna roll.
Wait, hold on.
Wait, what is it?
Circle or square?
No, it's X, right?
X.
Get on your side and roll.
There we go.
Stop!
It won't let me go any further.
No!
I wanted to do a story.
Stop!
Oh, he's gonna throw up again.
Gotta head out.
Take care, Vinto.
Thank you!
We're just about to end too, so no worries.
No worries at all.
What is that?
What is that thing?
What is it?
This is a lot of fun though.
It takes a second to get back into it, but we're back into it, I feel, so...
I will put on the other song and then we will...
Head out.
Sea Breeze.
Wait, not Sea Breeze.
What's the other one?
Wait.
Someone mentioned Sea Breeze earlier.
Theme of Tara.
It's so chill.
I hope you guys had fun with our first act of Metal Gear.
We'll pick it up again next week.
Not Saturday though, because I do have something on Saturday.
So it'll be probably Metal Gear Friday.
Probably we'll do...
A little later, since it is Friday and not...
Saturday.
But yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Thanks for the stream.
Thank you guys.
This is so much fun.
Oh gosh, I love this game.
I love this game.
I love this series.
I love it.
I love it, love it, love it.
We'll have a fun time with this.
If you don't know about the game.
And also I'm really excited to aim for the Boktai.
The solar gun, so...
We will try for it.
And try for also either bandana or...
Or camo.
One of the...
5 million is...
I'm gonna look up what's the best way to get DP.
I'm gonna look it up.
Because what if I can find like a...
What if I can find something and then just off stream I can farm.
You know?
That'd be great.
Be careful with that search.
Why?
I've
already played the game, so I don't have any spoilers.
I don't have any...
I don't have any spoilers.
Because I've already played the game, so...
If you're concerned about that, it's no worries.
Wait,
what?
It's bad phrasing?
Oh, it is?
Wait.
Is this something not good?
It stands for something else.
Is this something actually bad?
I'm scared.
Did I say something bad?
It's not actually bad?
Okay, I was really scared for a second.
I was scared for a second.
You scared me.
It's just NSFW, okay.
I thought I said something...
Something illegal.
I thought I said something really scary.
It stands for dragon punch, so you are going to get a lot of street fighter.
No!
Guys!
What the hell is this?
This is not the best is yet to come.
Actually, I don't think I can listen to this right now.
I think I'll cry.
Theme of Tara.
Yo, dead cell.
Come on!
Bust a move, snake!
Oh, sorry.
Collateral damage.
This is part of the break dancing process.
Oh, oh.
Thank you guys!
Otobito!
See you guys with more Metal Gear next week!
Bye bye!
I forgot to show.
I just remembered.
Oh no, I broke my computer.
Look.
Mental eye system.
Scanning.
Freak detected.
Executing operation 8008.